plague is notorious for causing mass
sickness and devastation but as much
tragedy as the disease has caused it
also helped drive crucial scientific and
social progress plague is an infectious
disease caused by the bacterium Yersinia
pestis it mainly affects rodents and
spreads by way of insects because of
these insect carriers plague has been
passed on to humans with devastating
consequences three major plague
pandemics have occurred in human history
and while they occurred centuries apart
they shared similar traits that paved
the way for the spread of disease one
cause of plague pandemics was the rise
of international trade trade routes
connected once isolated communities and
created large economic networks but by
facilitating the movement of goods
between communities trade routes also
facilitated the movement of germs
international trade was an impetus for
the first plague pandemic on record the
plague of Justinian in the 6th century
outbreaks began in Egypt and thanks to
land and sea trade routes they spread
throughout the Byzantine Empire named
after the Emperor at the time the plague
of Justinian is estimated to have wiped
out about half of Europe's population
growing economy is also made way for
urbanization and a rising urban
population this resulted in crowded
neighborhoods and accumulation of waste
which created unsanitary living
conditions cities and their residents
essentially became incubators for germs
and diseases
this was particularly evident in the
second and most infamous plague pandemic
in the 14th century Europe was
experiencing an economic and population
boom especially in cities proper waste
management did not exist at the time
making cities vulnerable to disease
after trade routes brought plague from
Asia where it killed millions in China
and the Middle East the disease wiped
out about a third of Europe's population
earning itself the moniker the Black
Death what also aided in the
transmission of the disease was the lack
of medical knowledge for most of human
history the cause of illnesses germs was
unknown making sicknesses like the
plague a mystery this lack of knowledge
drove the spread of disease as recently
as the 19th century outbreaks in
Northwest India eventually reached major
port cities in China in just over a
century plague was exported throughout
the globe and caused outbreaks and every
continent except Antarctica making it
the most widespread pandemic in history
this plague pandemic however was the
last in 1894 scientists discovered the
bacteria behind the plague outbreaks
their discovery helped further
developments in microbiology medicine
urban planning and sanitation methods
which led to the treatment and
prevention of the disease
economic expansion urbanization and the
lack of medical knowledge contributed to
the disastrous spread of plague in turn
however the disease helped catapult
crucial advancements in science and
public health very well making plague
pandemics a thing of the past
[Music]